a truce between Israel and the
Palestinian group Islamic Jihad it came
into effect on Saturday night with an
Egyptian mediated ceasefire after five
days of fighting many people in Gaza
have been left without a home the
violence began on Tuesday when Israeli
Air Raids killed three senior Islamic
Jihad Commandos at least 33 Palestinians
and one Israeli have been killed this
was the worst conflict between Israel
and Gaza since the 10-day war in 2021.
we've got two correspondents in the
story Muhammad Jam standing by in West
Jerusalem first we're going to go to
Villa Marx in Gaza Willem Gaza has been
through as we were saying several days
of attacks what's the atmosphere like
now
foreign
we arrived here from Southern Israel
over the course of this morning you can
probably hear behind me traffic is
pretty busy down on the street a few
stories beneath us stores have reopened
traders that are on the streets trucks
bringing supplies in and out of the
strip uh operation once again even the
fishermen have been allowed to go back
out into the Eastern Mediterranean to
try and catch their fish to sell in the
market over the course of those five
days from Tuesday through until late
last night we saw more than a thousand
rockets launched from this territory
more than 300 airstrikes targeting
individual places around the strip the
consequences for people here as you can
imagine pretty significant we've seen
more than 30 people killed the majority
of those here in Gaza City and then more
than 170 or so injured as well there are
many people here who have been impacted
by this their homes destroyed some of
their loved ones lost and so they'll be
looking to try and rebuild over the
coming weeks months and indeed years Rob
obviously this is a situation that we've
seen so many times before between Israel
and Gaza what do we expect to happen
over the next few days
well what would you imagine is that the
the authorities here inside Gaza will be
working with those families as a
priority who've been made homeless to
try and figure out where they can be
placed trying to essentially refit some
of the businesses that would have been
damaged try and get supplies flowing
back into the various stores so that
people have access to the products that
they need of course the longer term
question is going to be around whether
this kind of ceasefire that's been put
in place like late last night can hold
what the position of the various
factions inside cars will be when it
comes to their relationship with the
Israeli military
William thank you very much indeed well
and Mark's talking to us from guys I
want to bring in Muhammad Jam he's going
to be talking to us from West Jerusalem
um Benjamin Netanyahu the prime minister
of Israel obviously leading a coalition
which is has a very strong far right
element to it there's a lot of
speculation about how much pressure he'd
been under to agree to this ceasefire
what are we hearing from Israeli
authorities
well Rob let me tell you first about
what we've just heard in the past few
minutes uh speaking uh before the weekly
cabinet meeting uh prime minister
benjaminyahu made some remarks about
what the Israelis are calling operation
shield and arrow the campaign that have
been conducted in Gaza the past several
days the Prime Minister called it a
perfect campaign he said that due to
that campaign Israel had changed the
equation between it and the factions
inside of Gaza he said that his initial
instructions to the Army were two things
surprise and a preemptive initiative he
said that they had succeeded with the
mission he thanked the Army the security
forces and the intelligence officials
for carrying out this Mission
successfully and he also said that all
the top leadership of Islamic Jihad was
eliminated as a result of that operation
in Gaza now as you said the Prime
Minister has been under different types
of pressure on the one hand he was under
pressure from the far right member
members of his Coalition in order to act
more aggressively toward the factions
and we saw him do that in the past
several days as a result of this
campaign now there was also pressure
during the campaign from members of
those communities in the south of Israel
on the border with Gaza because you saw
Mass evacuations over the course of the
last several days you saw tens of
thousands of people leave their homes
they were starting to get worried that
this was going to escalate further they
want to see their kids back in school
they want to be able to go back to their
work open their businesses again so that
was another type of pressure but also
there had been another type of pressure
going on internally behind the scenes
because even though this campaign was
going on when you looked at what the
Israeli officials were telling local
media Outlets it was clear that Israel
wanted there to be a ceasefire and one
of the reasons for that is they did not
want to see Hamas get involved in any
kind of retaliatory strikes according to
intelligence officials in Israel they
never believed that Hamas were actually
inserting themselves in that fight that
was going on the past several days they
were worried about it they were worried
about escalation they kept warning Hamas
not to enter The Fray because they knew
that if that had been the case then this
was going to be a much wider
conflagration so those are the types of
pressures that the Prime Minister was
under right now what you see is
essentially him coming out saying the
quiet will be met with quiet and he's
essentially saying Israel will continue
to defend itself if there's a threat and
right now basically what he's doing is
addressing the country and essentially
taking a Victory lap saying that what
they've done as far as he's concerned is
protect Israeli citizens Muhammad in
West Jerusalem Mohammed thank you very
much and